[Musica]
fare fumetti
fare fumetti non è solo disegnare e
raccontare una storia cercare di
emozionare e usare appunto il disegno a
fare tutto questo
questo sono io sono nato 50 anni fa a 50
metri da qui
nel parco qui fuori ho giocato tutta la
mia infanzia
durante il terremoto nel 1976 sono stato
anche dentro le tende e quindi ho anche
dormito dentro a questo parco
mia mamma era disegnato vedere era
professoressa di storia dell'arte quindi
io sono nato in mezzo ai disegni in
mezzo
ai libri di storia dell'arte
ai compiti da correggere di questi
ragazzi è però i fumetti li ho scoperti
grazie a uno zio uno zio che arrivava
dalla puglia durante l'estate per riferì
gérard si dal caldo del sud e
si portava dietro un sacco di fumetti
perché passava un sacco di tempo la
colette quindi potete immaginare come
venivano utilizzati dopo mi regalava e
io ho scoperto su questi giornaletti
settimanali che esistono ancora adesso è
tutta una scuola di grandi autori del
mercato
sudamericano
argentino alberto breccia con zanotto ed
altri
per le immagini
tutte in bianco e nero che mi emoziona
vano talmente che sentivo quasi il
desiderio irrefrenabile di di emularli
quindi iniziavo anche a disegnarli però
non era solo quello che solo il fumetto
che mi
emozionava c'era anche il grande schermo
questi grandi registi come orson wells
come alfred hitchcock
avevano dell'inquadratura e talmente
ricercate che appunto io sentivo proprio
il desiderio di ricreare questa cosa e
non disponendo di grandi
mezzi perché all'epoca non c'erano i
telefonini digitali le telecamere
costavano tantissimo
vedete anche altri altri autori come
spielberg e ridley scott
io ho trovato il metodo che era più
consono più vicino alla mia alla mia
realtà e forse anche il metodo più
antico e cioè questo
questo questa qui è una bacchetta magica
secondo ma perché ti permette di
trasformare le idee in
emozioni e anche qualcosa di reale con
questa con questa bacchetta magica si
può creare qualsiasi cosa al posto
proprio di del suo solo prezzo
è di un pezzo di carta quindi possiamo
immaginare personaggi incredibili
vascelli i giganteschi
creature aliene
e questa cosa per me ha una magia
veramente
insuperabile
io disegnavo sempre dappertutto
a scuola sui diari dei dei compagni sui
banchi tra una lezione e l'altra sulla
lavagna facendo arrabbiare i professori
a casa addirittura disegnato su una
bella superficie liscia bianca che
avevamo in cucina anche dal frigorifero
e quindi mia mamma quotidianamente
andava a ripulirla
poi a 16 anni ho
scoperto che a pordenone c'era una
bellissima realtà fumettistica e ho
partecipato a un corso a questo corso
c'erano degli insegnanti che io vedevo
come adulti
ma che avevano 23 e 24 anni che mi
insegnarono i rudimenti del fumetto cioè
le prime cose
come il fatto che prima di disegnare
appunto ci vuole una sceneggiatura
oppure che i fumetti il disegno viene
disegnato un po più grande rispetto al
formato di stampa o ancora che bisogna
ripassare per poter essere riprodotto il
fumetto dove basta solo la matita ma
dopo vari passato a china e di solito si
utilizzano strumenti come pennino al
pennello
e tra questi in questo movimento oltre
ai disegnatori che insegnavano conobbi
anche una persona che per me è stata
fondamentale e salvatore oliva salvatore
oliva non era un disegnatore ma un
critico un appassionato un grande
esperto di hugo pratt che voi tutti
conoscete
e lui per me è fu oltre che un amico un
fratello maggiore e direi anche quasi un
gemello perché eravamo nati lo stesso
giorno abbiamo diversi il 7 dicembre
lui fu per me un mentore perché mi
permise di conoscere degli aspetti del
fumetto
che solo che da solo insomma ci avrei
messo un sacco di tempo quindi aspetti
autori realtà generi diversi
a me sconosciuti
e con lui ed emanuele barison emanuele
barison era è uno dei questi esponenti
uno dei disegnatori
pordenonesi di cominciamo anche a
viaggiare insieme andare a vedere delle
mostre a livello internazionale
soprattutto in francia e in belgio dove
le realtà del fumetto è molto evoluta e
nei nostri lunghi viaggi in macchina di
ritorno fantasticavamo dicevamo ma
magari un giorno anche in italia questa
questa sensibilità verso il fumetto
potrà essere uguale e
io con emanuele
cominciai a lavorare perché diventa il
suo assistente quindi iniziai a fare
le monetine del di zio paperone
lui lavorava per topolino
oppure gli sfondi per paperino o dei
personaggi secondari e
contemporaneamente però mia sorella che
per caso parlo con un art director di
una agenzia pubblicitaria
gli disse che io disegnavo e quindi lui
un giorno mi chiamò e mi propose di fare
un lavoro retribuito quindi a 16 anni la
possibilità di
guadagnare i miei primi soldini ed
immaginare di poter fare di questa
passione una professione
poi dopo dopo la maturità
mi trasferì a bologna per partecipare
proprio a un corso di pubblicità dove
c'erano dei professori che erano dei
freelance dei professionisti e questi
subito mi presero a portare a lavorare
per qualche agenzia e quindi a vent'anni
proprio riuscivo proprio a d'auto
sostenermi in questa cosa mentre
contemporaneamente
lavoravo sempre con emanuele per fare
l'assistente sui fumetti quindi avevo
questi questi due fronti i miei genitori
insomma erano contenti di questi primi
risultati però insomma volevano
desideravano che io facessi una
professione un po più sicura quindi
speravano più vi scrive se l'università
o fare ingegneria eccetera ma io insomma
avevo già chiaro quello che volevo fare
nobile vuol essere un creativo
quindi non necessariamente solo un
disegnatore proprio un creativo perché
mi piaceva proprio esplorare tutti i
vari aspetti
di queste possibilità che mi offriva
questo strumentino qui
un giorno però mio papà al ritorno da
bologna mi disse ma senti ma perché non
ti trovi un lavoro magari part time
durante il pomeriggio poi fare i tuoi
disegnati
questa cosa mi colpì parecchio no perché
insomma io ero già tutto gasato
però dopo capii che appunto la
preoccupazione di un padre era insomma
limitata proprio alla sua esperienza
mentre solo io potevo capire e sapere
quale potrebbe li poteva essere il mio
futuro è solo io potevo combattere per
realizzare i miei sogni è così
e così insomma con intraprendenza
passione e anche un po di ingenuità mi
sono proposto ai vari mercati e questa
cosa
semmai mi ha portato anche dei risultati
abbastanza immediati sono stato il primo
disegnatore italiano a realizzare una
copertina dell'uomo ragno ho fatto
la copertina di un famoso disco degli
ho lavorato
per videoclip famosi di vasco rossi e di
zucchero questo
questo videoclip è stato girato
da roman polanski quindi questo grande
regista
conosciuto nel nel cinema
e poi ho fatto anche appunto qualche
campagna pubblicitaria importante questi
qua se questi sono gli storyboard sono
gli studi che vengono fatti per poi
essere dati ai ai realizzatori poi
quelli che
che riprendono proprio le scene e queste
esperienze trasversali mi hanno poi
permesso di
arricchirmi di competenze che dopo io ho
portato anche nel fumetto quindi
successivamente
sono approdato al mercato francese che
come dicevo è il più prestigioso al
mondo
lavorando con con case editrici molto
molto prestigiose e anche conferendomi
anche dei riconoscimenti
queste sono alcune immagini poi ha
lavorato anche per la disney ha creato
proprio io stesso che è un privilegio
proprio concesso pochissimi dei
personaggi
proprio per la disney
e poi infine qualche anno fa ho
realizzato anche un albo specialissimo
di tex che mi ha dato anche grandissima
riconoscimento anche in italia
ecco in tutto questo la mia parola
chiave è sempre stata quella
dell'esplorazione no quindi lavorare
sempre con grandissima curiosità quindi
avete visto ho esplorato diversi generi
diversi stili mi piace continuamente
provare a utilizzare strumenti in
maniera
non convenzionale
a me piace addirittura usare anche il
eyeliner del trucco per fare alcune
parti in nero e questa ricerca abbia
portato addirittura inventa fare un
brevetto aveva inventato un metodo per
usare la matita sui tablet disegnare
proprio sui tablet
questo successo a livello internazionale
però
collimava con con una grande passione
che io però per la mia città io ho
deciso di dopo la mia esperienza
bolognese di ritornare a pordenone
restare a pordenone nonostante che
lavorassi a livello internazionale e
fare la mia famiglia però coltivare le
mie amicizie rimanere vicino alla mia
famiglia è però voluto anche trasferire
tutto queste conoscenze che io avevo
anche al mio territorio e così nel 2000
ho fondato un'associazione culturale che
permettesse anche ad altri giovani
artisti di tutte le discipline di
cimentarsi nella loro passione e anche
realizzare i loro sogni e dopo una
decina d'anni è la mia città mi ha anche
conferito una loro efficienza insomma
che concesse a pochi cioè dico di fare
in vita
una mostra al personale proprio qui in
questo posto dove tutto era iniziato
vediamo se va questa mostra
in cui ho chiamato proprio salvatore
oliva che conosceva benissimo tutta la
mia carriera conosceva tutti i
retroscena la passione ed era stato
anche colui che mi aveva aiutato a
realizzare i miei sogni a fare il
curatore di questa mostra la mostra fu
un successo un grandissimo successo
e fu anche una grandissima soddisfazione
perché raramente in italia il fumetto
era entrato in una galleria d'arte
contemporanea
questa questo questa esperienza ci diede
modo di pensare
di creare un luogo unico quindi pensai
di
proporre questo progetto ma il progetto
insomma fu rifiutato evidentemente i
tempi non erano ancora maturi per il
fumetto come strumento culturale e
quindi mela me simile mela visivi meno
visivi a
successe però che la galleria dopo
qualche anno cade poi disgrazia quindi
anche l'area urbana esterna qui fuori
diventò un po mal frequentata e questa
cosa mi faceva
profondamente soffrire e così ho
riesumato questo progetto
questa volta chiamando degli altri
professionisti non tutti i fumetti stima
di provenienze diverse un amministratore
delegato un architetto un esperto di
marketing per riformulare in maniera
impeccabile questo progetto e
ripresentarlo in maniera vincente e così
è stato ci siamo trovati per due anni
sul divano del mio studio e più
lavoravamo su questo progetto che ci
rendevamo conto che quanto fosse potente
lo strumento del fumetto come veicolo
culturale e
insomma abbiamo ovviamente incontrato
tantissime difficoltà in questa cosa
perché potete immaginare la diffidenza
verso qualcosa di nuovo la difficoltà
nel reperire i fondi
per far restare in piedi una realtà del
genere
però insomma la motivazione è anche dada
pordenonesi in questa cosa non ci ha
fatto mai desistere e poi personalmente
insomma io avevo una motivazione ancora
più grande perché nel frattempo
salvatore ci aveva lasciati gli avevo
promesso che avrei realizzato quanto
avevamo sognato insieme e questa questo
luogo lo abbiamo inaugurato proprio il 7
dicembre il giorno del suo compleanno
che mi emoziona
è un posto
vediamo se ecco è un posto trasversale
un corso innovativo aperto giovane
moderno
che per me che dove facciamo un sacco di
cose che riqualifica l'area che ha una
sensibilità sociale
ed è diventato in tre anni e dalla sua
nascita uno dei luoghi più prestigiosi
d'europa dedicati al tema del fumetto e
di questo siamo veramente contenti
[Musica]
ecco la quadratura del cerchio sta nel
fatto che tutto nasce sempre da qua da
una storia dai disegni e la cosa bella è
che in questa storia di successo c'è una
radice che parte tutto dalle sonde al
sogno di un bambino
grazie
[Applauso]